[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
where was mr ashcon coming from that
night
well the evidence is going to show
that the last thing on mr edge comes to
mind
was first degree intentional homicide a
wisconsin man stands trial for a murder
he argues was done in self-defense and
the murder retrial gets underway for
accused killer deonte rizillas in a
florida courtroom plus convicted sex
trafficker elaine maxwell formally
requests a new trial after concerns over
a juror's past but first after just a
few hours of deliberation a verdict is
decided in the chandler-halterson murder
trial law and crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the jury has come back with a
guilty verdict in the trial of a
wisconsin man now convicted of murdering
and dismembering his parents after just
a couple hours of deliberation the judge
read the jury's decision in court
the verdict form on count one as signed
by the presiding juror and dated today
reads
we the jury find the defendant chandler
m halderson guilty of first degree
intentional homicide as to barde
halderson
the verdict form for count five as
signed and dated reads we the jury find
the defendant chandler m halderson
guilty of first degree intentional
homicide as to krista r halderson
law and crime sierra gillespie was in
the courtroom as the verdict was read
she joins us now live at the dane county
courthouse in wisconsin
brian guilty on all counts that is what
a jury of chandler halderson's peers
determined on thursday here in madison
wisconsin in less than three hours that
means the 23 year old is now convicted
of the murder of his father 50-year-old
bart halderson and his mother
53-year-old krista halderson now i was
in the courtroom at the time that these
many guilty verdicts were read it was
more crowded than i have seen since
opening statements in fact the bailiff
told me he marked off an extra row today
so that friends and family of bart and
christa halderson could sit in for these
closing arguments and as the verdict was
read so noticeably absent today though
was mitchell halderson that's the
brother of chandler halderson and the
son of bart and krista he was not in the
audience
as these verdicts were read or the
closing arguments were made but all eyes
that were in the gallery were focused on
defendant chandler halderson halderson
has remained pretty consistent
throughout this trial something we've
discussed quite often is he doesn't have
much emotion he pretty much stares
forward blinks in response and even as
prosecutors were detailing the vicious
crimes that happened in their closing
arguments he pretty much remained the
same stone cold here but that is what
happened inside the courtroom in madison
on thursday guilty on all counts
guilty and convicted now of the murder
of his father and mother brian
thank you sierra joining us today is
civil rights attorney suanne robinson
and terry austin swan for weeks people
have been curious about what the defense
would or even could be were you
surprised at the speed of the verdict
after seeing their closing
no absolutely not and apparently the
defense wasn't very surprised because
during her closing argument she said to
the jury i can tell by your faces your
mind is already made up but give me a
chance and then went into some more for
argument so we weren't surprised or i
wasn't surprised in the least i mean the
fingerprint on the canvas
and absolutely no uh explanation given
for anything not that he had a burden to
prove anything but he didn't put forth a
defense at all um so
just just a very sad situation a
horrific crime and glad there's going to
be accountability
now terry i'm curious there was a part
in the prop if there's a part in
prosecution summation or even the
rebuttal where you thought yeah he's
guilty
yes the beginning middle and the end i
thought he was guilty all along based on
the evidence that we heard there was an
abundance we know he was the only person
who came into that house we know that
his parents never came out of that house
there's no question that he lied the
entire time so i thought that the
closing and also the rebuttal were quite
clear quite succinct i did think that
there was no reason for the prosecution
to accuse the defense attorneys of lying
the judge after the objection by the
defense said listen to the jury it's not
intended to say that they were lying
just listen to the evidence don't worry
about what they're saying in these
summations but overall i thought they
did a good job and overall i believed
every word that they said and so did the
jury yeah i'm actually surprised that it
got to i think it was just over a little
over two hours but i know we were
commenting during the break that maybe
they were just waiting for their lunch
to come in because it does seem to be
that the fact that the lunch came in
then they made the verdict shortly after
because i thought this would have been
done in minutes sierra where do we go
from here and what sort of sentence
could we see and when
brian this is something we've discussed
here on long crime daily in fact people
have brought up oh the death penalty is
this something that chandler halderson
could face but in the state of wisconsin
the death penalty was abolished in the
1800s so that is completely off the
table here sentencing is set for march
and what could happen here based on his
first degree intentional homicide
conviction two counts of it in fact he
will likely face life in prison now the
big question mark here is whether
hulderson will be up for parole at some
point or if it is forever life behind
bars here in wisconsin so that is
something that we will continue to
follow again in march is when that
sentencing uh hearing is set for and
we'll continue to follow and bring you
the latest on on that sentencing as it
happens yeah it's gonna be interesting
to see how that plays out because don't
forget he's convicted now of killing his
parents i would assume that there'd be
so many family members talking at a
victim impact statement but not for the
defendant for the victims of course
we'll cover that when law and crime
daily comes up next for the sentencing
of chandler halderson thank you everyone
still ahead on law and crime daily and
accused murderer is given the option of
a plea deal in the florida case of
deante rozillis as his retrial gets
underway the first concern over a juror
in the federal trial of gelane maxwell
is prompting her defense team to
officially request a new trial just a
month after she was convicted of sex
crimes
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
three former minneapolis police officers
involved in george floyd's death will
have to wait a few more months for their
state trial to begin but jury selection
began in their federal trial on thursday
two taowan rookie officers thomas slain
and alexander king face charges of
aiding and abetting derek shovin in
violating floyd's rights in may 2020.
chopin pled guilty to violating floyd's
civil rights in the hearing last month
he was already serving a 22 and a half
year sentence in state prison for
floyd's murder the state trial for tau
lane and king is now scheduled for june
also in federal court former girlfriend
of jeffrey epstein elaine maxwell is
formally requesting a new trial less
than a month after being convicted of
sex trafficking charges the motion for a
new trial was filed wednesday prompted
by concerns about post-trial media
interviews with one of the jurors he
revealed he talked about being sexually
abused as a child while in jury
deliberations legero told media outlets
that his experience impacted the jury's
decisions maxwell was convicted in late
december of sex crimes related to
recruiting and grooming young teenage
girls to be sexually abused by epstein
she is set to be sentenced in june she
faces up to 65 years in prison
prosecutors should reply to the request
for a new trial by early february
back to discuss maxwell's plea for a new
trial is civil rights attorney suanne
robinson and terry austin terry we
discussed this before and we're a little
confused but talk to us about why it's
odd that the defense is asking for a new
trial and not a mistrial
it does seem odd i mean you say potato i
say potato let's call the whole thing
off listen whether you call it a motion
for a mistrial or whether you call it a
motion for a new child the result is
going to be the same if the motion
prevails maxwell will get a new trial a
motion for mistrial brian can be made
during the trial or even after the
verdict if it's based literally on
something that the jury has done but the
motion for the new trial is going to be
made after a verdict so the reason for
the confusion is that the prosecution is
the party that decides whether or not to
bring the new trial so it seems a little
odd for the defendant to be making a
motion for a new trial technically
they're making a motion to vacate the
decision and then the prosecution is
going to bring the new trial but it
really is very similar it's just the
timing of when the motion's made
understand now suanne based on what we
know of this juror and deliberations
would you expect a new trial or were the
facts so strong a court would just say
hey this was a harmless error she's
guilty
i mean the facts are extremely strong
and you know at the end of the day
the fact speaks for themselves there's
no reason for guillain maxwell to have
been recruiting all these young teen
girls to be in her home
with
epstein there's absolutely no reason
they weren't running a daycare they
weren't running a dance school there's
absolutely no reason but
they she is entitled to a fair trial
under the constitution and i think the
case law might be in her favor because
the juror did not disclose their
background at the time yeah added to
that he's saying that this actually
impacted the jury's decision i think
that could be the strongest argument for
the defense we'll of course see how the
prosecution replies in that case coming
up on law on crime daily a murder
retrial begins with an offer for a plea
deal in a florida courtroom ahead of
jury selection and the deontay
rizzilla's case plus prosecutors and
defense attorneys state their case in
opening statements during a murder trial
in which the defendant theodore edge
cove is claiming self-defense
[Music]
welcome back a convicted killer now
awaits an answer from the georgia
supreme court after his lawyers file an
appeal for a new trial tex mcira's
lawyer won his murder conviction tossed
they say he did not have a fair trial
when he was tried for killing his wife
five years ago mackeiver is serving a
life sentence after a jury found him
guilty of felony murder in the shooting
death of his wife diane in 2016.
prosecutors proved he had financial
motive to kill her the defendant's
attorney argued to the state supreme
court that there was overwhelming
evidence that the shooting was an
accident he cited witness testimony from
both sides describing the couple's
relationship as quote marital bliss the
justice has also addressed allegations
that the prosecution interjected racial
bias into the case mciver's attorney
told the justices the jury wasn't given
the full scope of possible charges
many of the cases you know including the
pre-reigns cases and the pre-cook cases
do involve you know grabbing a gun and
and then it goes off accidentally as all
the defendant says it goes off
accidentally and the court says well
that's that's a misdemeanor involuntary
manslaughter because we don't have any
intent to shoot the gun at that point
there's no intent to point or shoot the
gun
then then that could be accidental a
jury could have found accident the jury
could have found
uh involuntary misdemeanor the jury
could have found involuntary
felony but what what happened in this
case is we deprived the jury of that
fact-finding role
the court will make a decision on the
appeal in the coming months
and jury selection began in a florida
courtroom thursday morning in the
retrial for deontay razillas police say
he allegedly stabbed a woman to death
during a home invasion robbery seven
years ago
jury selection started only after the
defendant turned down a plea deal in the
case
rozillis is being retried for the murder
of jill halibur and sue prosecutors say
the defendant broke into sue's home in
september of 2014 thinking no one was
home they say once he realized sue was
there he stabbed her tied her up and
left her in a pool of her blood in a
bathtub razillus is charged with
first-degree murder for the crime while
in custody razillas also escaped the
courthouse during a hearing with the
help of several accomplices he was on
the run for six days before being caught
rizzulus's case went to trial last year
but ended in a mistrial on thursday
morning rozillos was presented with a
plea deal to take the death penalty off
the table but he turned it down coral
reconvened monday morning
back to break down the bizarre retrial
is civil rights attorney suanne robinson
and co-host terry austin terry just
before retrial rozilla says offer a plea
with no death penalty it's 100 his
choice i totally get that but do you
think he should have taken the plea
brian i definitely think he should have
taken that plea this was a brutal crime
she was found tied up she was stabbed to
death and they found you know his dna on
the knife and he was definitely at the
scene because that puts him at the scene
and they have security footage of him
fleeing the scene and allegedly he
basically had some robberies in some of
the other areas at that neighborhood so
i think that if all of that evidence
comes into this trial he will be found
guilty and he'll be facing the death
penalty so it probably would have been a
good idea to take that plea yeah maybe
he's thinking because some of the jurors
were torn in the first trial that may
happen again but suanne many people
believe that retrials favor the
prosecution what are your thoughts on
that idea and how do you think the
defense will fare in this case a second
time around
i think you're right statistically
retrials do favor the prosecution but
you know you never know the defense has
the opportunity to kind of revamp
whatever they presented originally and
make it stronger so you never know this
actually his escape actually occurred in
my home court right here in broward
county and it was just a very
interesting time when when
it's very rare that it happens so it was
just a very very interesting case and an
interesting time when that occurred but
i can tell you this you know sometimes
the clients want to take it to the door
and as a defense attorney they have the
right to to do that so you defend your
client as best you can and i'm sure
they're gonna do it in this trial as
well yeah it's their choice to testify
it's their choice to take a plea you
can't really make any other decisions
for them in those two areas so we'll see
how this case continues
when we come back opening statements and
an eyewitness account paint the picture
of a murder in wisconsin we discuss the
case of theodore edgecombe when lawn
crime daily continues next
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
prosecutors describe the scene of when a
man allegedly shot and killed a
wisconsin attorney as the murder trial
for theodore edgecombe got underway
wednesday in milwaukee edgcom allegedly
shot and killed jason clearman in 2020
when the two got into an altercation on
the road prosecutors say edgecone was on
a bicycle when he punched clearman a
passenger in the car through his open
window clearman's wife was driving at
the time video shows the couple followed
edgecomb onto a bridge as he rode away
clearman got out of the car that's when
edgecombe shot him edgecone was arrested
six months later in kentucky he's
claiming it was self-defense
the prosecution painted a picture for
the jury of what happened when jason
clearman was killed
mrs clairman pulls over
the victim
sadly gets out the defendant pulls out
his nine millimeter hand
and he raises
it and he shoots the victim
in the face
and then the defendant
picks up his bike
and either steps over the victim
or walks right by him because the victim
is falling down onto the stairs you're
going to see how his blood is literally
pulling and going down the stairs he
walks right by this man you have her
checks on it
never gave him a warning
he just pulled out a gun shot him in the
face and then he leaves
the defense argued the entire incident
was started by the clearman's
the evidence is going to show in this
case
that the clear bits will specifically
jason clearman yelled out get the fuck
out the road
he goes to the car he asks mr claremont
where you talking to me
mr clement says yes
racial slur i was talking to you
and that's when mr escombe punches
mr clearman the claremonts
could have went straight after this
incident they could have you know got a
description instead
they didn't just follow mr adscomb
the evidence in this case is going to
show they chased
mr edgecombe
an eyewitness took the stand thursday he
told jurors what he saw happened
the guy was pretty much
forced off the street by the car because
he fell
off his bike trying to get up the curb
he proceeded to run
towards the stairs of the
of the bridge right there
and then that's when the guy in the
passenger seat
gets out the car
and proceeded to run after the guy
uh he forced him into a corner as if he
wanted to engage in some into something
with them
and when you're saying engage um
did you see the person who got out of
the car do you see him do anything yep
he put his fist up so he has his fists
up
in a boxing stance
what's the biker do
he then
pulls the gun
i believe i don't know if it came from
behind or out of a bag he pulls the gun
and then shoots the guy in the head
so and how did you feel the defense did
in their opening both in facts but also
in their tone
i think the defense did a pretty good
job i mean you have a case where you
have to assert your clients right to
self-defense you have a case where on
video they're being followed and you
have to really give the jury that sense
of urgency that your client felt at that
moment that they definitely felt like
their life was in danger because he was
being followed now by this person who
initially provoked him i mean there
isn't if you look up words that could
provoke a fight in the english language
i think that racial slur is probably one
of the very first words so it's very
difficult for you know
um for for um the prosecution and the
defense to keep this case kind of calm
and cool because it has such
evocative language yeah absolutely now
terry how would you grade the
prosecution's opening did it give you a
good road map of the case to come
you know what brian i'd give him a b
plus it was succinct it was clear but it
was a little bit on the short side in
other words he could have given more
details he gave a road map but it was
only 10 minutes long and the details he
provided they were somewhat
inconsequential he mentioned the fact
that the defendant had a nice bike no
one really cares about the fact that it
was a nice bike why is he giving that
particular detail and it also seemed to
me that it was very one-sided he kept
calling the deceased the victim and he
kept calling the defendant the defendant
making the jury believe one is good and
one is bad so i also think he tried to
avoid the use of the you know slur
and it is a very provocative word suan
is absolutely right about that so it
looked like he was avoiding something so
he gets a b plus not an a yeah avoidance
is not the best thing you want as a
prosecutor we'll see how it plays out
but thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you